[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to another
episode of
[Music]
congratulations right man
yes dude we're doing it eyes are teary
because we had to down a perrier before
we even started uh so i could get that
out and i got two dude or as calvin
would say
because that's what he says for two but
we're here and we are ready it is a very
spooky episode of congratulations just
like we do every year this is probably
the third maybe halloween we've done i
don't know
and you know we get real spooky dude and
that's uh instead of going you know you
know you do the trick-or-treatings and
you ever you always hear the people
how is that not phased out don't know
but it hasn't it's still around you walk
around town october 31st you hear
but anyway dude we are that spooky
that's how spooky we are dude that's how
frank and spooky we are so anyway dude
um i'm if for those of you that don't
know that live under a rock
for halloween i'm rick sanchez and i'll
tell you what dude
um
my dogs are in cells and that's why we
hear them uh they're in cells for
halloween just like they are every other
day of the
of the [ __ ] year dude i don't like my
dogs yes don't think about them ever
when i'm on vacation i don't even
[ __ ] think about any of them except
for cooper yes dude
i don't and then i come back and i
[ __ ] sometimes don't even pet sam for
three weeks
yes dude
sometimes i don't even pet butters for
even longer than that because where is
he all the time yes
but it's all good dude we're having a
good time we're having a good uh you
know uh uh
month a good holiday dude i hope you
you have or had i don't know when this
is coming out but a good i hope you got
lots of candy and all that [ __ ]
now the costume i will tell you this i
obviously didn't have uh
much creative say in it i did absolutely
decide on being rick for halloween but
you know it's like uh
it is it is what it is i wanted to do it
like this showed it to calvin and this
is what he does when he sees it he
didn't see me getting ready for it
showed up he was watching some [ __ ]
show that's like i oh i love apples and
beninis i love [ __ ] oranges oranges
and bananas and [ __ ] i'm like calvin
what's up and he goes and he goes like
that this is what he does well he's
watching the show and he goes like this
this is how his dad looks all right he's
been alive a year and a half the only
thing he's ever seen is me in me mode
okay
so he goes i'm like this is going to be
great this is what he does stuck in his
stuff that's what he does
give a [ __ ] about apples and bananas
more than his dad dressing like for all
i know my son's [ __ ] hero at this
point i don't know i mean he's seen rick
and morty before but what i am saying is
my head itches yes
did i just wash my hair and i need to
wash it again to take this blue out yes
did i want to do this no did i want to
just put the [ __ ] unibrow with the
tape on it yes did kristen have other
ideas for me yes is it okay yes am i
gonna build resentment for it yes will
it not come out until a few months later
yes but it's fine dude because i'm in
therapy man
okay so i'm figuring out how to be real
chill with my emotions i'm figuring out
how to make it go from mach 11 anger to
right about margate
mark 8.5 mach 9 maybe mach 10
back to mach 11 but we're we stayed
trying to do you know what i mean she
saw it
um so yeah she's like let me just and i
know dude the [ __ ] thing is always
like
every
anytime she's trying to do something
she's always like let me just you know
and if someone says let me just i'm just
like
the answer is no
you know
no let me just
so she's like she's like trying to
[ __ ]
uh
she's like do the have the
have the
we're gonna paint your eyebrows and i
was like you got the unibrow why don't
we just tape it on and she's like it's
gonna look way better i'm like no it'll
be [ __ ] funny or if it's just and
she's like no trust me your eyebrows are
good that's why people say you you look
like rick anyway
and i'm just like all right fine and
then she did this and she's like i'm not
i'm like don't put on my hair and get it
ready because i want you to
put it on i don't want to be i'm i'm
watching something on youtube you know
and she was like okay well i'll just put
it on a [ __ ]
pumpkin and then did the hair and then
put it on and it itches dude yes does it
itchy yes
and it itches real bad but i'm keeping
it cool dude i remember i had to wear a
wig once for a movie i did five years
ago and oh my [ __ ] god dude couldn't
wait for it to be done i'm an ingrate
anyway um
yeah dude so i i'm she's getting ready
she's getting the costume ready and
she's putting it and she's like let me
just do this and that and we have to cut
some [ __ ] in the back but then she's
like can we just do this and that and
then i even get rid of his like because
i'm looking miserable and he's like wow
you're really excited to do this han i
said you know what dude i'm just [ __ ]
basically rick
i'm pissed i'm [ __ ] upset that i got
to do this fun [ __ ] but in real life
under that
i'm happy to make you happy dude because
everybody you know you learn it like
halfway through the season that rick's
kind of got a little bit of a heart you
know he won't admit it but he does
anyway dude [ __ ] is getting real spooky
um
so yeah dude and i don't have enough of
the [ __ ] i've never done the show
without the headphones but we're go
we're it's on it's on and popping dude
it's on it's on him popping um you know
and then i looked at my notes and i was
like dude i have so many actual serious
topics to talk about i can't wait for
the clips to come out and [ __ ] you
know your boy goes [ __ ] stupid viral
he's gonna that's gonna be a [ __ ]
it's gonna be [ __ ] viral stupid viral
tenfold and i'm going to look like this
and people are going to be like why the
hell is he talking about the alec
baldwin thing but he's looking just like
[ __ ] rick sanchez so i basically get
down can't talk about anything serious
but whatever we will we will anyway do
it what are they going to do
what are they going gonna do cancel rick
sanchez
um
so yeah i probably could start off with
this lady goose time dude i [ __ ]
posted this thing on tik tok about the
island boy
i'm an islam boy wagon
boy am i
and i did the [ __ ] tick tock
on the thing
and i put on tick tock and so many
people were like wow [ __ ] bullying
the island
wow you're a piece of [ __ ] wow can't
believe you're [ __ ]
talking [ __ ] grown man talking [ __ ] to
these 21 year old [ __ ]
island but oh you said you think they're
white they're cuban you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
you're sad [ __ ] you bullying hey
didn't we all agree
this [ __ ] sucks
now i gotta [ __ ] backtrack and be
like oh oh oh oh yeah everyone's talking
[ __ ] about the [ __ ] island boys
and and that now i'm doing it and now
under the comments wow bullying hold up
did we agree
didn't we agree these two dudes suck
and now i gotta [ __ ] now i'm the
islam boy waguan
what's going on what one dude
what might the heart pick on the movie
on the area what
it's no
jaka blamel
[Applause]
and i'm just sitting here like one do
so anyway i'm a [ __ ] i you know now
i'm the island boy cause everyone's
talking [ __ ] about me i'm under my tick
tock dude stay making friends in the
comments you can get the merch
you can get the merch make a friends of
the comments there's new merch there's
the sandstorm merch there's also some
[ __ ] merch that's very important
nowadays to flex at the gym with
it's coming up i don't actually know if
it's out yet but if it is we'll put it
out if it's not we're not gonna talk
about the podcast yet but dude um yeah
man people just don't get jokes it's
weird like and everyone's bringing up
the chappelle thing too is the main
thing like everyone's like i'm like bro
this i'm just this is a joke you know
i'm a comedian and they're like [ __ ] you
dude
[ __ ] you you're bullying and then other
people are like this is exactly what
dave chappelle's talking about this is
exactly what he's talking about
i'm so
i've i've taught i've talked about the
dave chapel thing i'm not going to talk
about it again
um and it's all good but
whatever i actually look like a [ __ ]
island boy actually now that i think
about it i have this literally i have
the same i'm the blue hair island boy so
great awesome tried to be rick sanchez
um
what guan do
uh
so yeah so everyone was mad at me uh on
tick tock for posting that island boy
[ __ ] but it's all good i'm gonna
probably make it through the fire and uh
be a better person afterwards um i can't
even see my [ __ ] uh we saw dune dude
i saw dune
every dude i saw all right look no knock
no knock to nothing
beautiful movie all right let me just
say started off
thought i was watching
a cologne commercial
everyone looked
handsome as [ __ ]
i mean they looked so good aqua did
giorgio was watching this movie
three minutes in it goes like this
he swallowed
on nothing okay three minutes in aqua
did giorgio drock mr noir
just watching this movie like this
but they know our secrets that's what
they're but they know our secrets
mr the boss of hugo
second seen in the dune he's like this
how'd they figure out
how did they figure out this
how'd they figure out what's in this
dude everybody is so handsome in this
movie the chicks
are handsome as [ __ ]
did there's some dudes in the movie then
chicks show up oh the chicks could ask
women out on a date
the chicks
are walking down
like an a dimly lit street
with a wet asphalt just like
they're handsome as [ __ ] the chicks are
in contention with the chicks
that aqua de georgio's getting right
it's unbelievable how handsome everybody
dude everything everyone everything is
so [ __ ] handsome in this so i'm like
all right it's beautiful this can be an
experience
dune
i spell it d-o-o-n
because that's what dune
should be spelled like
i guess it's dune because it's you know
dunes
i didn't read the book i bought the book
read one page so far and uh it's
a lot different
the first page is a lot different than
the first
it really is it doesn't start with him
eating with his mother using the voice
she's like use the voice you know
he's like can i have this can i have a
water
they got this voice where you can make
people do [ __ ] with by the way it's
scary as [ __ ]
it's like the force with star wars but
it's the voice and actually dune was
written before that right
so star wars um say what you want but
so
she's like can i have some water like a
16 year old kid and the mom's like use
the voice and then he's like
get out of some water just like did it
with like the [ __ ] voice dude
you see the movie i know everyone did
but he's just like dude imagine me in
that part
hey could you pass the water use the
voice all right get out of some water
and then just you pour it without even
here you don't even know right that's
what happens in the movie kill him
you're just like kill him and then you
jump out of the airplane
and then you have to do it dude it's
like the force only it's the voice
anyway dude timothy chalamet's hilario
but they use
effects on it but i would try to do it
i'll naturally be like i'll do dune but
i'm not you know you're not using god
damn it how much better would the movie
be if for real he was just like could i
have some water
that would be so much better dude i'd be
like immediately right there timothy
chalamet congratulations you happen to
be the new nick cage you're my new
favorite actor okay
um
so i'm watching dune
and everyone's handsome as [ __ ]
right even the [ __ ] jets the copters
that flap their wings stupid as [ __ ]
we figure you know what i mean just
because it's the year
3955 million or whatever it is
doesn't mean the airplanes didn't
already figure it out in the year 19
whatever it was when the wright brothers
came together but they're flapping now
dude dune has the [ __ ] we're flapping
now timothy chalamet just like get a
little look up through and they [ __ ]
get in and they're flapping now dude
and it's like all right dude all right i
i i'll see if this sinks in right
because sometimes you watch a movie and
you sit and you're in a world and you're
the world hits you over the head with it
and you're like i don't know i don't
know but halfway through you're like
okay all right i can get it i could i
can i figured it out i got it with the
[ __ ]
flap i can i can get in i i get maybe
the this is dune's world i came in a
little bit like me and dune wanted me to
be living in dunes world okay
so
every actor is in this [ __ ] movie
from josh brolin to
that [ __ ] old woman who plays his
grandmother
that's in uh ozark
and uh i'm watching the movie and i'm
like an hour in and there's one fight
scene and they s and and and it's one of
those movies that every thing is
something new it's like a science
fiction it's like yeah the harkenings
and the israelites and the ice and the
aids and buddhism and the nodes 19 like
every other word is a word you
understand and i'm like all right i
gotta [ __ ] under okay
okay
okay this is what science fiction is
science fiction happens to be one of my
favorite genres okay it really happens
to be one of my favorite genres it's
between you're probably like oh chrisley
what's your favorite genre comedy no
comedy is my least favorite besides
[ __ ] like independent movies that
think that they're so good about drugs
or like a movie about like a family
going through a hard time that has a
[ __ ]
joel edgerton in it you know which by
the way is a [ __ ] banging actor but i
just don't want to see that movie it's
gonna have so much brown in it like he's
gonna be wearing a flannel and have a
beard and the sun's gonna be [ __ ]
dressed in long johns and i'm just not
about that movie how about that all
right
so i'm watching dune
and uh
and it's got so many of these words in
it
that i don't know what they mean because
they're created by the [ __ ] guy who
wrote the book in 1976 or whatever the
[ __ ] it was and then it gets to the part
where they have to one of the characters
says
they're describing a way to become one
in the sand with yourself and how to use
the sand for your advantage
this is what the fremen do another group
of people
labeled by a word that happens to be
made up
foreign should it be free man yes is it
not yes it's fremen does it piss me off
yes it's like in the [ __ ] movie with
tom cruise minority report and his
[ __ ]
character's name
his last name is anderton just make it
anderson all right we've talked about
that before in this podcast but just
call the freman freeman wherever they
said freeman i'm just like add an e
dekwad
dickwood
so um
so so now
uh i'm watching it and they get to the
point where they describe how you use
the desert
and the guy fucking's got the nerve to
say
that's called desert power
why'd we get off the train here
why'd you stop unpacking the suitcase
now
why'd we take a rest
nine tenths up the track
why do we do this
make if you're making a name for an
entire race of people if you're making a
name for a 400 meter worm that swims
underground if you're making a name
for planets that by the way you created
that don't exist
then make up a name for having power in
the desert okay that right there
i paused it and i looked over to chris
now here's my ex first of all here's the
other thing too
i love josh brolin i love josh brolin
he killed it when he played thanos right
he really killed it
he was wasted in this movie
he was wasted in this movie he did one
scene where he fought and he should have
been more like [ __ ]
hello timothy chalamet right but he was
just like come on come on you know like
that typical general i wish it was more
creepy whatever that's how i would have
played it dude i can't wait to [ __ ]
do a part
it's over it's over
any insecurities i ever had with any
director should i say this should i make
this choice i'm doing crazy [ __ ] anyway
um
so
now they're they're calling it desert
power and i pause it and i look over to
kristen they say desert power like three
times in the movie by the way i look
over kristen and i'm like what the [ __ ]
huh
and she's like it's so great and i say
the movie and she's like i love it and
i'm like
ah for [ __ ]
oh for [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] sake
why and i say why do you love it and she
says because it's beautiful it's an
experience and like and i was like yeah
but the story though and she's like
well i don't know i like it i'm like oh
for [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
okay fine but i rested
within myself
knowing that when we were done with the
movie i was going to look up the reviews
and i was going to be right and not only
that i was going to comb the internet
for fans and what they said
so
i turned it off slept on it woke up the
next day checked it
everyone [ __ ] loved it
everyone loves the movie
so i guess i'm wrong dude i guess that's
just how it's gonna be okay yay [ __ ]
you win world
everyone likes dunes so i like dune i'm
changing my [ __ ] opinion i don't i
don't know movies anymore goddamn desert
power
[ __ ] desert power that's what you're
gonna call it
[ __ ] ass dude call it something
italy call it desert magic
power
that's like something jean-claude van
damme would say in a movie
that's because we have
that's because we have desert power and
you'd be like well yeah that's what
[ __ ] that's the writers they got
you know what i mean
that son of a [ __ ]
we're going to get him well how are we
going to do that
john for some reason that's your name
even though you're [ __ ] so obviously
from from belgium
not jen
john john
we're going to use desert power
and you're like oh okay
that's what [ __ ]
and then you google the writer and he
wrote like this and another thing called
like [ __ ]
cabin in the valley that was that was
like
the fifth guy from csi was the lead of
it and it came out in [ __ ] night
2002. anyway dude um
dunes fine
everyone likes it and they already are
making the sequel and i'm like dude just
don't set the movie up how did it i
don't
i don't know dude and then i was talking
to somebody that loved the movie and
they were and i was like
dude it just seemed like everything i've
seen before and they're like well yeah
but dune was first and i'm like you're
right dude all right i lose then i
[ __ ] lose
you're right you're right it was before
star wars they're using the voice
[ __ ] luke skywalker uses the
the
force
and timothy chalamet and dune [ __ ]
says can i have some water
um
but it is what it is dude
there's a lot of stuff going on in the
world though
uh
oh [ __ ] speaking of halloween michael
myers uh
the movie came out halloween kills it's
called there's like 20 of them jamie the
curtis is still in it
usually movies that just keep going and
going
like eventually they're like all right
to the first like like johnny depp isn't
still in friday the 13th reboots and
[ __ ]
but uh
jamie lee curtis is is still in it and
and usually they're like okay you're 90.
[ __ ] it we let's
she's in it though
um and um
i i watched it uh half of it just to
kind of
see it
and then i saw
i googled movies always after i googled
it and i saw the headline
that uh
now michael myers
is canceled because he's
homophobic
and that's a real thing that i read on
yahoo
that people were covering because there
was a twitter outcry
about how michael myers is homophobic
because he killed two
gay
uh a gay couple in the movie and
michael myers
uh
is not
homophobic he just kills
the problem with michael myers isn't
that he's homophobic you know
that's not the problem
the problem with michael myers is that
he's a psychopath killer
and even still
he's not real
you can't be homophobic
if you don't exist
right
hey
jiminy cricket
you're racist
hey
they're three little pigs
you're toxic
no
you're not
because you don't exist
clavorp
you're sexist
right now you're probably like who's
clavorp
he's no one
i made him up
you know why
he doesn't exist
so that's the same thing as saying
michael myers you're homophobic
michael myers has a butcher knife and
stabs whoever's closest to him but also
more importantly than that michael myers
doesn't exist
so he's not even really stabbing anyone
also
how about this people who are mad that
michael myers is now homophobic
don't you want to be included
isn't it right
to include everyone
nowadays you need to be inclusive so
shouldn't michael myers
be stabbing the [ __ ]
out of whites blacks
jews
uh homosexuals
trans people
uh
you know short people also
he hasn't killed a short person yet that
i've seen
sure people should be angry at him
you can't win
imagine your platform is [ __ ]
imagine on your platform you're yelling
about the wokeness of a [ __ ] slasher
film
i just can't really understand things
anymore and i suppose
that's just how it's gonna be for me
because what is it gonna get better i'm
what is one day i'm gonna wake up and
i'm just gonna get the world
the older you get
you get smarter i guess
but it's not like you learn
[Music]
what
the while you learn more
the exponential
uh
you exponentially learn
what you don't know
and
you're [ __ ] you know after
i mean 40
you're just like oh there's so much i
don't know and
there's going to be a whole much more
that i don't know
i think that's why we end up
dying it's just the weight of you know
people get curvy as [ __ ]
right
they just [ __ ] shrink a little bit
it's because the weight of what the [ __ ]
they realize they don't know
is just like ah [ __ ] that's so heavy
what and then one day they're like i'm
gonna croak and they don't even know
that they're subconsciously doing this
but it's just like
[ __ ] man that's why people have heart
attacks and get cancer they're just like
i i
don't exactly want to kill myself but
god damn
we all gotta [ __ ] get desert power is
what we gotta get
michael myers included gay people and
that's why i think that michael myers is
an ally for lgbtq community
um lgbtq [ __ ] did i say it right god
damn it
yes i did say right
i did say it right yay go me
um
i love this [ __ ]
here's another thing that does anybody
online ever are they ever nice you know
like i saw virgil abalo's new shoes
that he's coming out with
they're mid
uh
um air force ones and the at first when
i saw him i was like ah cool
i liked them
i looked on many posts
and there wasn't one good one one good
comment
and i hope these [ __ ] honestly
mean it
because i want to get them all right
and it's too hard to get the shoes man
you got to wake up at like seven o'clock
or pay over price and that's just like
i'm not gonna do that for these at least
but i like these shoes so [ __ ]
i didn't see one good [ __ ] thing dude
about these shoes
even my friends were texting look how
horrible these are
once you get to be the top dog man
everybody hates you but where's the love
though
where's the love
you don't see it
right
like all everyone talks about on twitter
joe rogan is how
how much they disagree with his opinions
you know what i mean
he's the number one [ __ ] guy
elon musk
i mean
really honestly the only people that
tout elon musk on
social media are like frat dudes
but everyone else is like oh [ __ ]
what a quack
where's the love dude
everyone [ __ ] hates jeff bezos i
don't know dick about jeff bezos
oh wrong one hell yes
that's the right one
but where's the love dude
i don't [ __ ] know
my head [ __ ] hurts from this [ __ ]
um
i guess spreading more love or whatever
is what i'm trying to say how about this
[ __ ] alec baldwin thing jesus christ
man i didn't really want to get too
heavy because of this [ __ ] wig i'm
wearing but jesus christ dude it's
timely
alec baldwin
i mean no everybody knows i'm i guess i
got to explain it to lead into it but
like alec baldwin
had a gun given to him that was loaded
on set and he shot
through the camera and killed the dp or
the camera woman and um
she's dead she died
um
the fact that anybody first of all let
me just say this
let me just start by this
i don't know how um
that happens at all okay i don't know
how that happens at all
i've been in
on set holding guns and firing guns
and
it's
very obviously not a gun that works it's
a gun that is plastic
or some metal components
and you shoot it
and it goes
and it's air that comes out
and they you can put the fire the cgi
[ __ ] in later
okay um
so
even on that set they would be like
don't point the guns at anyone yeah it's
just air but you never know
and nobody did that nobody did it the
whole set was flooded with guns nobody
ever
did anything like that
the fact that there are still guns like
real guns being used on sets
at all
is is just not it's so stupid it's just
dumb right
one life is too many
and this has happened
multiple times
um
everyone is now
[ __ ] on
the
woman i believe who
got who was the uh
handler i forget what they're called
armorer
uh and she got the job because her dad
was someone who was important in the
industry and everyone's saying this is
what happens with nepotism she didn't
earn her position sure
of course that's wrong
um this woman apparently went shooting
with
the gun
before this
and then somehow it wound up on set and
it was given to the ad
and then the ad gave it to alec baldwin
now nobody should touch guns on set
except for
the props person
and then also the actor using the gun
um
that's often not the case you know
because it's just a rule and people
don't abide by it but this is what
[ __ ] happens
uh
everyone is
want you know screaming for this woman
to
look
my friend texted me this woman should go
to [ __ ] jail
she ruined so many people's lives
and i wrote back i might be way off here
but it was a mistake yeah it's horrible
and he's like but she affected people's
lives it's manslaughter even though she
didn't mean to she was like i was like
well i i guess i don't know really what
technically manslaughter is but i
thought it was like drunk driving or
you're getting a bar fight and they're
not killing someone you don't really
intend to kill someone but then they end
up dying
she was not trying to do any harm here
she was trying to do her job albeit it
was a really bad job
her life
guess what is over no matter what right
her life is over whether you shame her
or not
she
has to feel
the worse she's ever felt and by the way
probably the worse she's ever going to
feel and that's going to last a long
long long long time
people are mad at alec baldwin most
people are who are mad at him are have
what i've seen online are the
republicans that are way for gun control
way against gun control because alec
baldwin was an outspoken person
saying
we need
to have
less deaths and
you know
i guess he was
wanted
an advocate of gun safety or if i don't
know if you didn't want them or why i
don't i'm not really clear on alec
baldwin's whole stance on gun control
but i know he isn't a proponent of it
and um
now like donald trump jr and [ __ ] are
posting like countless memes about
how dumb alec baldwin is and
you know i'm not i don't believe in like
the whole shaming culture and [ __ ] like
but like if if there is shaming this is
what it is
um
they're shaming alec baldwin in oh you
know i i'm a respectful gun owner i have
[ __ ] 60 guns and i've killed less
people than you have
and it's like putting it like donald
trump jr put something
like this up and
everyone is like oh [ __ ]
uh ha ha [ __ ] alec baldwin
not everyone you know people are are in
support of him but this was a mistake
and guess what this is probably the
worst thing that is ever going to happen
or has happened to alec baldwin his life
is forever changed and guess what
all of your memes and [ __ ] attacking
these
people
and
trying to make them [ __ ] want to end
their own lives
um
it doesn't
change what happened and how about the
fact that somebody died
for real
during this accident
this is the thing i never understood do
it and i see some comedians doing it too
it's like the quickest to make the joke
oh [ __ ] this happened gotta make a
joke about it what about the fact and i
make a lot of jokes dude
i never am the guy i've never i've never
done the thing i gotta be first to talk
about it oh i gotta do this joke before
someone else does it i don't give a [ __ ]
about that [ __ ] never have i ever been
like that um
but i see these people that are like
trying to make these [ __ ]
first jokes which are terrible [ __ ]
jokes and this
husband and her kids
or one kid or two kids their their their
life is forever changed dude their life
is forever changed alec baldwin's life
is forever changed
it's [ __ ]
puts it into perspective a little bit
and now i haven't always done that in my
life
but i have a [ __ ] platform
look should she work as a [ __ ] armor
ever again
probably not should she go to jail i
don't think so
it was a mistake
i feel really [ __ ] badly man i see
that [ __ ] and i don't know if it's
because like i'm in a different place
now or i have a son
or
all of the you know
ptsd that i have about the internet or
whatever the [ __ ] but it puts me in a
real [ __ ] [ __ ] place man and i start
crying because
people lose focus of the fact that
this family is ruined
i mean this
this woman's dead and this husband
doesn't have a [ __ ] wife anymore and
these kids or kid or whatever i can't
remember if he was one or two kids they
don't have a [ __ ] mom anymore
and now i got to see along with the rest
of the world that picture of her behind
the camera that's this beautiful shot of
her doing what she loves
and i got to know who she is because of
this
and i'm not saying in a selfish way but
there's no reason why i should know or
anybody should know who this person is
because they should just be living their
[ __ ] life
and
not everybody knows what the [ __ ]
happened
you weren't on set
oh god i'm so sick of people [ __ ]
doing these
yeah whatever pushing their agenda you
know
it is what it is
nothing i say is going to change
anything
and michael myers is [ __ ] homophobic
for [ __ ] sake
i was on stage the other night and i did
no let me just tell this actually
i woke up
it was a day i don't remember what day
it was but i woke up it was like a week
ago nah it was less than that i i was in
a [ __ ] mood i was [ __ ]
not happy at all
uh all day cried twice during that day
i'll be honest [ __ ] it i know a lot of
people are gonna watch this episode
because i'm in a rick wig and i didn't
want to [ __ ] talk about this but who
gives a [ __ ] look i cried twice that day
for i don't even know what reason i just
started crying okay i was alone most of
the day uh except for in the evening or
in the afternoon i was playing with
calvin and it was very bittersweet
because i was in a [ __ ] mood and i was
playing with calvin and i loved being
his dad and um there was a point where i
was so deep in the darkness that
i was like trying to
just focus on calvin
to make sure that he felt loved and i
think i was able to crack a smile but it
was just shitty all day and i told uh
this booker that i would come down and
do a set
all day i was thinking i'm not going to
be funny i'm not good um i don't want to
do this i haven't done i've only done
stand up a few times since i've been
back what 20 times
and i feel like i don't have the chops
to [ __ ] overcome this emotion um
uh i don't know what's going on with my
body but
i just don't feel right going on stage
but i told the guy i'd go and he was
counting on me to go so i thought you
know what i don't i don't want to go but
i told the guy i would go i got to be a
guy who says what he means and
my first show ever
ever
my first show ever when i started doing
stand-up i remember being so [ __ ]
nervous
that
uh i was like how am i gonna get on
stage and i thought if i just put my
legs in the direction one by one by the
in the in the direction of the stage and
then i got on stage uh
i would be on stage and then i would
have to talk so i'm gonna make my body
move
even though my mind doesn't want it to
and i did that and i went on stage and i
had a find set whatever
but now here i am again and i'm in a
different situation i'm in a darker
place i've had a rough year and a half
whatever the [ __ ] it is
i can't
shake this horrible feeling and and i
don't want to uh
underplay the feeling it was a very dark
feeling that um i couldn't i just
there was no snapping out of it
and
i thought here i am again i don't want
to go down to the to the
laugh factory i don't want to do this
show
but i made my body get in my car i made
my body drive down to the place and i
drove down to the place and i sat in my
car for 20 minutes i didn't want to get
out of the car and i thought you got to
make your body [ __ ] go
into at least go into the laugh factory
after 20 minutes i did i walked in
and
the guy this the the woman there says
hey
glad you're here the next comic uh isn't
here do you want to go up next
and i say and i and i i listened to the
crowd and the guy in front of me is
murdering and i think
oh [ __ ] i'm still really upset
and i don't have the chops right now to
go on and do well after this guy
who is absolutely murdering
but i gave up i gave up on the feeling
of darkness i gave up on the feeling of
feeling
shitty
and i made myself say
yeah [ __ ] it i'm gonna bomb
but i'll go up and she said ah you're
not gonna bomb or something and i said
uh we'll see
so the guy gets off stage everyone goes
nuts
and they he comes off and he's like hey
are you on next and i'm like yeah he's
like hell yeah kill him i was like dude
there's no way i'm gonna [ __ ] do this
i'm not gonna be able to do this
so
he says he laughs she says be fine so i
get on stage
i get a really big ovation when i go on
stage
and um i do my set
for some reason
it's
the best set that i've had in
five years
i don't understand why
something about the energy
something about how i felt like this the
deck was stacked against me
the awful feeling that i had all day for
hours and hours
for some reason
just turned into this moment of
in my mind
it felt like
this magical [ __ ] thing i was on
stage
people were laughing when
i thought they should laugh
and when i was quiet they were listening
nobody was trying to ruin any punchline
or
nobody was woo
it was all
it was like perfect
and i put the microphone down i say
thank you
and the whole place stands up and they
give me a standing ovation
and
i walk off stage and i'm in
now back into the world i had this crazy
bad day
on stage i let it go it felt like magic
and now i step back into the world
and
immediately guys want to give me hand
shakes
girls are out there hey with their fist
bumps and dudes are fist bumping the guy
says hey will you sign this for me i
grab a pen i'm not even looking at what
i'm signing and then i realize it's the
menu to the laugh factory that i'm just
defacing right
and i walk upstairs
and i'm by
myself
and i don't really know how to process
everything that's happened because when
you go on stage every single time it's
like
you hear this big train going by and
you're just like okay
this is going to be not what life is
usually like for the next however long
this train lasts
and that's how long your set is
it's not normal people are just staring
at you and life is different for a
little bit
and it's loud and it's fast things are
happening that you're not really uh
you know
used to in your daily life as a comedian
you are but that's only when you're on
stage
so i'm now i'm sitting there alone and
i'm alone again
and i remember
how i felt 30 minutes before this
and i remember how bad it was
and i don't feel that bad anymore
i actually feel
okay
and then this guy comes up to me
and he says hey chris and i say yeah
and he says
i gotta say
and he gives me a compliment
i'm not going to tell you what the
compliment is because number one i don't
want to seem like i'm bragging
and i can't do that without telling you
what a guy
said when he compliments me for and
number two i don't want to tell you
because that's for me
it's for me and this guy told it to me
and it was special and it was nice
he gave me the compliment and then he
walked away
and he said thanks and i said no man
honestly you made my day thank you
he walked away
and i
cried
for the third time i mean i burst out
but it was for a different reason it was
because
i got through the day
and
it was hard
but i just made my body do the things
that it needed to do
and now it was a different time and i
felt differently
and ain't that
just how this podcast goes where the
time i'm going to tell you a long
emotional story about a dark period i
had
in a [ __ ] rick sanchez halloween
costume
but that's how it goes
and
that's when it happened and i just want
to let you guys know
that that happened
because i know some people
listen to me
and struggle
with their own things
and
you're listening
i'm talking
we're
together
right now
i'm not the smartest person here with
all of us
okay i just happen to be the one talking
and you guys happen to be the ones
listening
i say i'm not the smartest one i'm not
the most emotional i'm not the most
talented
but i am telling you
if i can get through that day
and not be any of those things the most
then i know
you can
so that's that and i thought about
telling you this next week because i
wouldn't be dressed like rick sanchez
but
no that's not how it's gonna be
there
um
what else happened that's [ __ ] funny
oh that [ __ ] night dude no no not
that night that [ __ ] it was a night
before
this is [ __ ] i get on stage i'm
talking about [ __ ] on stage like all the
[ __ ] i went through and
uh
uh my family and my fiance and my kid
and
and i get off stage
and i go to thank the people running the
show
and this uh
i go to the thing and i and i get a tap
on my shoulder i turn around and it's
this beautiful woman right
and she's like hey
that was great and i say oh thanks and
she says
you should come get a drink uh with me
after this
and i [ __ ] laughed very hard like in
her face i didn't mean to
partially because
look uh
my act was all about my family and my
fiance and
this struggle
and partially because
this is it dude
this is the moment
where i can either
uh crack or not
and
i laugh and i say oh
oh
i would love to but i
can't just like that i said it just like
that
and [ __ ] the
the
[ __ ]
promoters laughed hard right
and i'm because we know what the [ __ ]
going on and she says oh god cause she
was taking a bath because i laughed and
she said how come
she said are you sober or something
and i said actually yeah
and they laughed even harder and it just
felt good to
like i was talking earlier be a guy who
[ __ ] said i uh
be a guy who can struggle but also wants
to be
uh
true to his word
yeah but it was [ __ ] funny as [ __ ]
man we were dying
we were dying and then she had a [ __ ]
purse that had a christian dior it said
chris it said kristen dior and cd and i
was like oh those are my initials y'all
got to get out of here and i [ __ ]
left
uh
yeah
that was funny
i told it to kristen
and we laughed and we laughed
i'll save that story for next time
um
[Music]
dune huh i don't
know what else can we talk about is
there anything else that that i [ __ ]
did i miss anything that happened
oh dude
the [ __ ]
how about the fact
that
i'm
smart as [ __ ] dude
i know people dude if there's one thing
i know it's people i don't know things
like math and science and all that other
[ __ ]
things about the earth dude bye bye i
don't know about you but one thing i
know about is people now
either one or two episodes ago i was
talking about the property brothers and
i said about the property brothers hey
guys
there is no way one of you
don't have
knight's armor set up in your [ __ ]
house
and guess what dude
they do
they do one of them has knights armor
set up in their [ __ ] house
they have that
i know that and i know that not because
i saw that i know that because of course
those guys are those guys
and i want you to understand how much i
know people because that's how i did it
i'm like the simpsons when they
predicted everything about [ __ ]
donald trump and [ __ ]
you can go back and be like the simpsons
really predicted everything how about
the fact that i predicted also really
important things too
like the property brothers happen to
actually have
a [ __ ] night so i just know dude i
told you about the story once when i was
with my one of my exes and she was like
we were talking about some guy down the
way and she was like
i was like you probably like that guy
he's handsome hun she was like yeah
something and i was like yeah i was like
i was like uh
we got into an argument about who knows
people more and i was like pic pick
anyone
and she said what about that guy said oh
yeah that guy you like it's cause you
like that guy you think he's handsome
she's like no she's like i don't know
like whatever and i'm like you think you
know more about people than i do all
right cool i'll tell you right now that
guy makes his own furniture and she goes
that's the [ __ ]
thing that's the thing you want to say i
said yeah she had balls not actually you
know what i mean she had like
gusto or whatever the [ __ ] she walked
over she didn't give a [ __ ] she's like
i'm gonna go walk up she sits down talk
to this handsome hunk
looks over me like what the [ __ ] comes
back he says yeah he actually made a
[ __ ] he does he makes like he made
his table in his house and he put
together his cat i'm like dude
even i shot me with that one but dude
sometimes your first [ __ ] go-to [ __ ]
is
i think sometimes we have this [ __ ]
sort of like
i read that book the gift of fear
and it was like
it lets you know
that like that thing the whole thing
women's intuition that [ __ ] is real
because that's how it keeps us alive
um
right
like there was one story in that book
where
this guy
all of a sudden knew he was gonna get
robbed in his car and he didn't know why
until like weeks later he realized maybe
he saw
some like something he saw he saw the
guy coming out of his rear view mirror
in his
peripheral
view but he was like but that shouldn't
be weird to me because the rearview
mirrors or the side mirrors you always
see people from coming from behind you
but then you realize that the reason why
i knew he was gonna get robbed is
because if he actually thought about it
um
that image in that side mirror
was
moving was moving way quicker than
normal so he knew something weird was
gonna happen my point is you can pick
[ __ ] up
and you don't even know why
maybe that guy was [ __ ] with his
hands like how i saw him another guy
[ __ ] with his hands that used to do
manual labor or some [ __ ] i don't know
but i guessed furniture making and he
makes his own furniture and your boy
[ __ ] deserves a medal for that
doesn't deserve a medal for turning a
girl down for a drink but definitely
deserves a medal for understanding that
that dude
definitely absolutely makes some
furniture and also one of the property
brothers has a [ __ ]
knight's armor in his
house so that's it that's that the
episode that was the halloween episode
it was very spooky i know i'm sorry to
scare the [ __ ] out of you um but just
remember
uh make friends in the comments of this
and brush up against that like button
and absolutely [ __ ] unbelievably
obliterate that subscribe subscribe dude
you know what i mean
hey guys that's the episode on youtube
uh to catch the rest of the episode
all you have to do is sign up for our
patreon patreon.com crystalia and uh you
can get the extended version of this
episode and also
uh we do one
episode a month uh that is extra and um
that's on our patreon and you can get
access to all those back
uh episodes on our patreon on our
patreon it's six bucks a month
so we appreciate you and uh bye-bye
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
thank you
oh so annoying babe so so annoying here
we go ready